We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David p.
I know some people are going to be mad about
this voicemail.
This is a voicemail from a caller who is sending
an angry message to Bernie Bros.
Okay.
Don't shoot the Messenger.
This is not my position.
This is what a caller says.
Take a listen.
Hey David, this is Ken from southern California.
Hey, listen to all those Bernie Bros out there
as they call themselves.
You know, unless you want four more years
of the Pussy grabber, Donald Trump, who is
against everything you for.
Even if Joe Biden is the nominee on the democratic
side, you need to vote for him.
At least he is for 75 or 80% of what you're
for.
You don't.
If you don't want four more years of this
pussy grabbing orange piece of [BLEEP], I
don't think this nation can stand then you
Bernie Bros better both from whoever the Democratic
nominee is, even if it's Joe Biden.
Thanks David.
All right, so listen, I mean, they're very,
very angry.
Uh, but there is some important message in
there as I've said before, which is let's
make sure that our spirited primary doesn't
end up enabling Donald Trump to get reelected.
I am a progressive, therefore, Joe Biden's
politics are to my right, and I'm going to
be supporting someone who is further to the
left.
But if Biden's the nominee and it's Biden
versus Trump, I'm voting for Biden.
I've made it clear and I think that that's
the primary message there from Ken, uh, calling
in from southern California.
We've got a great bonus show for you today.
Become a or a patron
to get instant access, and we'll speak more
then.